who's in the film Tyler main source
Tyler main Muse Watson derek mears three
pretty large horror film icons Taliban
was michael myers and Rob Zombie's
Halloween series Derek Mears was Jason
and friday 13th and also predator in the
most recent predator films and
amusements and who played been the
fisherman with the hook and I know what
you did last summer and a lot of the
horror film fans have been wanting to
see Jason and Michael fight so this was
kind of like a cathartic you know film
for them hopefully to see them go
head-to-head they're not those
characters with at least the V actors
that play this character and I think our
film is a little bit you know it's a
supernatural thriller so it was a little
bit more of a characterization and a
story going on then a lot of slasher
films that you might see it goes a
little bit more emotionally in depth
into those things the characters their
motivations that kind of thing so I
would imagine you saved a ton of money
by not filming in Georgia and that's no
i think we probably did it there was
discussion that it would probably save
us money to film in Georgia but I I
don't know man like I'm glad we didn't
tell you that right now I wouldn't been
able to do with so many close friends if
I didn't do it in LA it was so much
easier I can go home at night you know
it was nice how long was this shoot 18
days we also had two day we had one day
of like first-team pickups and I did a
few look insert shots here and they're
so total of 19 20 days and whereabouts
did you film it we shot most the film in
santa clarita there was this house that
we had scouted out on newhall ranch and
it was this former CEO of new halls
house and it was in it for I think 12 or
13 years I was kind of run down but it
was really cool looking and it fit a lot
of the needs that we were looking for
it's hard to find an isolated house in
California I mean you can you can find
some but exactly the script needed a
certain look into certain surrounding
and you have
trees there's a treehouse written into
the script so there's a lot of stuff
that we needed to have there was a very
you know specific set of needs that we
had for our location and that one fit
almost all of them the ones that I
didn't fit we made adjustments to the
script based on that but when I was darn
near perfect and we were the only people
that had shot there was it haunted that
was a haunted uh did any of your gear
move or didn't know there was a lot of
weird noises in the forest outside of
the tree into the trees and stuff I
always thought there was some kind of
animal stalking me whenever I would go
out to the restrooms that were like on
the outskirts of the set how do you know
here's something the woods and I always
felt like I was being watched or
something I thought me and it felt like
it was something like a large animal of
some kind like a like a panther or some
kind of I just imagined it being some
kind of large cat that would probably
tear me apart so you know I carried a
knife of me when I was around on that
set just because I didn't want to you
know run into any it's like hunter
what's the country now but I was really
in it i think the security guards and
several people who were at their
overnight for whatever reason our
department whenever we kind of here the
same noises and we're all speculating
what that was could have just been the
wind but it's more fun to think it's
other things right what did you shoot on
we shout out to read up well so it was
one right epic was shot on one red epic
single camera shoot and we used aerial
trip I'm area ultra Prime's as this as
the lenses arranged from I think i had a
14mm all the way on up to 85 primes
people ask me what I shoe and I always
talk about the glass because to me
that's more important than the camera
itself because the glass really defines
the look of the film and I really like
the way that area ultra primes flared
and what the flare was an important part
of the style that I wanted in this film
any time there's a ghost Erick in my
opinion whenever there's a specter
present in the film spoiler alert I
wanted to be some kind of flaring going
on the lens almost like it was affecting
the camera image because I've read a lot
about how ghosts can affect the camera
image sure they chant you know they they
cause the orbs aberrations of some kind
yeah orbs or flares or things like that
for me I wanted to be flares it was
something I could usually accomplish
without having a visual effect and it
was something that I also liked the way
those lenses looked so I could
incorporate into the visual style as
well as subliminal subliminal things
that are going on the filming as well so
when you watch the film most people are
going to notice that but I notice it so
yeah there's just some things in the
film that are kind of like second or
third level viewing type details like
with the flaring and there's also a
strange region there's a fly just
constantly around Gary muse Watson's
character and it starts with the first
time that he senses a presence and that
and the fly just landed on his face and
it like caused him to look over where I
needed him to look exactly at the right
time and this fly just kept coming into
the frame whenever I needed it to come
into the frame and doing that same thing
at one point a fly lands on a space
again the exact same place and it was
like halfway through the film like days
later and it's the same looking fly the
same and it landed there for a good
amount of time exactly how long I needed
it for just a halt freak freak
occurrences but that fit perfectly into
the film fit perfectly into the the
rules
the world that we create it was the fly
Union haha you know I never got to ask
him he flew away before I get a chance
you